you've seen many different examples of
page structures but we haven't explored
how the browser knows what style to
apply and where that style comes from
let's take a deeper look at how it all
works together HTML is the language of
the web and it has a specific syntax and
rules you write HTML in a document just
like you would regular text except you
follow HTML syntax and rules rather than
general grammatical rules the basic word
in the language of HTML is a tag the
browser turns HTML tags into elements
that form a tree it knows how to do that
because of the document object model or
Dom which is a standard convention for
representing and interacting with
elements in HTML so the tree you saw in
developer tools was really the Dom tree
that the browser built from an HTML
document each HTML tag creates an
element in the Dom that the browser uses
to display the page an element is
created from the starting tag to the
ending tag and everything in between is
content the content can be empty it can
be text or it can be another element
each tag has a name or type that defines
what kind of element will be created
will it be a paragraph an image or just
a document division block each tag can
also have attributes with values for
example here we have an h1 tag with a
class attribute and a value of that
attribute of article the document
written in HTML defines the structure
and content of the page to define the
style you have to use another language
CSS CSS allows you to use a specific
syntax and rules to change how elements
look on the page the size of the font
color background borders position and on
and on for example you can use CSS to
a all h1 elements that belong to the
class article should have the text color
dark blue to tie structure and style
together the HTML document can provide
the browser with information on what
style to use and where to get it
since there are specific rules for how
these elements work once you know the
language you can look at the HTML code
and get a pretty good understanding of
how the page is organized and what it
can look like and it works the other way
around too you can see how a page looks
and get an idea of how you can break it
down into different elements which is
what we're going to do next